[Music]
this is Paris 1789 a chaotic and brutal
time I'm Alex Amancio creative director
on Assassin's Creed unity co-op play and
deep customization have been the most
requested features from Assassin's Creed
fans while we've heard you and now with
the power of next gen technology were
able to deliver a massive leap forward
in gameplay what's your name boy
ah no Victor Dorian yo clay is our know
throughout the story you'll be able to
take your customized assassin online to
play co-op missions with friends and
unravel the secret story behind the
French Revolution this is what happens
when you give command of the government
to half-starved lunatics in command of
the army to bloodthirsty savages every
assassin has a core set of skills call
that navigation
and stealth from that course you can
build up talents and experience to grow
out your own skillset unity is the first
Assassin's Creed to incorporate a deep
regression system each skill or asset
you choose has a critical influence on
your gameplay for example if you want a
tactical advantage to assassinate a
target in a large crowd try clipping
your assassin with a lower profile hood
that way you can more easily blend into
the crowd and use your eagle sense from
a longer range there are no rigid
classes or roles in unity you can start
with your basic stealth specialty where
you are pure stealth almost like a
shadow
or the meili place time where you focus
on attacks that deal high damage then
there's a range class where you can
focus on parkour navigation and killing
from above and the health specialty or
even with sand enemy attacks then you
craft the custom play style that mixes
the mastery of all the different skills
over the course of the campaign you can
pick up specific weapons in gear that
will round out your roll of choice the
phantom blade a modest little update
from the traditional assassin's blade
every element will define your path and
gameplay style for example the heavier
the armor the more protection you'll
have but you'll be less stealthy how can
you sneak through a sewer in these
threads and the more agile the weapon
the more defensively you can parry but
your blows will be less damaging there
are thousands of possible combinations
of items and weapons it was carrying
this collect and combine them as you
craft your unique assassin you should
keep it it'll do no one any good
moldering a difficult route even the
best assassins are stronger together
join up with your Brotherhood for two to
four player co-op each assassin playing
a complementary part of the team thanks
to deep customization
new skills allow each player to
specialize and share their advantages
with other players communal sense shares
eagle vision and disguise
what's a player disguise himself and all
his teammates to look like citizens of
Paris group healing shares healer powers
and assassins cash but steams stock and
share balms you can attempt any
Brotherhood mission alone but the newly
designed player rating system makes it
easy to find the right team for the
right fight each co-op mission ties into
a specific event in the French
Revolution and ultimately into the
Brotherhood itself you follow us shortly
Robespierre shall be beaten down so all
missions are open-ended allowing for
tactics and teamwork
they are also replayable so you can find
new loot each and every time work
together to play better play off each
other specialties with customized
loadouts
once you master one area whether it's
stealth parkour or ground combat pick up
and hone another skill after all in a
revolution this bloody they must adapt
or die make history Assassin's Creed
unity pre-order now for 2 bonus offers
the PIA team spindle end game get a
chance to win prizes every Friday
and the explosive chemical revolution
mission pre-order now available November
11th
[Music]